hello everyone and welcome back to the
good stuff we are continuing the morphe
saga and we are continuing the match
well not continuing we're actually
beginning the match in the previous uh
video we've shown
uh how morphe lost the game to reverend
john owen and
it is basically how the uh owen defend
the defense came into existence so they
played two friendly games one was won by
morphe one by uh john owen
uh and then morphe challenged to uh to a
match where he
will be uh down upon so as you can see
morphe is missing his f7 pawn
which morphy does fairly often against
weaker opponents it's actually not even
a problem because he already gets the
open
a semi-open file for his rook but
against uh
the earlier opponent it could prove to
be a problem so
let's see how our good friend john owen
deals with this so him
with the white pieces uh goes for e4 he
uh and now knight to c6 by morphe with
d4 and e5 we're not going to be naming
any openings as well black is just
missing an f pawn
so knight f3 and now e captures on d4
with bishop to c4
if he had the f1 it would be sort of a
sort of a scotch gambit as white
didn't recapture right away we have
queen to f6 by morphe
going for extremely rapid development
here and uh owen castles with d6 by
morphe
and knight the g5 now with some
uh threats on the f7 square here and
morphy goes knight to h6 he def he
defends the f7 square
we have c3 now uh offering morphy more
material
uh uh to get more pieces into the game
but morphe ignores it bishop to g4
continues development
attacks the queen with f3 uh pushing
morphe's bishop back bishop to d7
and now bishop to d5 very strong idea
uh just uh centralizing that bishop and
waiting for
black to to to to play a move so uh you
could castle queen side you could go
bishop to e7 prepare kingside castle
morphe actually decides to capture on c3
and help
white to develop a knight so knight
captures on c3 and only now bishop to e7
so it is a
it is a weird decision by morphe but i
still don't think morphy thinks uh much
of
mr john or reverend john owen here but i
i don't think morphy thought much of
anyone that he faced in those days so
here we have knight to b5 going after
the c7 pawn
uh to create some some sort of a fork
here and bishop d8 morphe defends the c7
pawn with
f4 now and knight the e7 now
uh putting pressure on the bishop by
really threatening uh c6 which would
just win material
so knight back to c301 and bishop back
to g4 now that the pawn has moved to f4
we have queen to b3 now with uh with a
basically a triple attack oh this is
something new the bishop can actually
point an arrow to the g7 pawn now that
is weird that is weird
uh that is really weird i don't know i
don't know why that that is possible
but basically a triple attack on the f7
square and here
morphe just goes c6 c6 inviting
inviting the bishop to come in but here
we have a very interesting idea by owen
uh he doesn't go for something like
queen captures on b7 to attack the rook
or bishop to e6 to prepare something
he rather just goes e5 he wants to open
up the f file for the rook as well so
here we have d
captures on e but now knight's the e4 as
the e4 square has been vacated for the
night so now uh there's a really some
wild action going on here morphe first
goes to bishop to b6
check uh forcing king to h1 it's not
forced you could also defend with bishop
to e3 probably
would be even better uh but okay king to
h one by owen and now queen to g6 morphe
finally moves the queen out of harm's
way
and now asks what do you want to do here
and here we reach the position from the
thumbnail
we have bishop the f7 checked by owen
forking the king and the queen
luckily for morphe he can capture with
the knight which he does so knight
captures we have knight captures
and now uh the problem is what um
owen thought morphy would do he probably
thought morphy would capture and then uh
he would go for knight to d6 check for
king the queen
or the other thing if morphy goes for
this knight then again knight to d6
check for the king and queen this way
uh but morphy did none of those things
he went for
knight to d5 now he blocks the queen's
attack to the night and now he can
capture this knight
and well not right away because he still
runs into this but
now there are ideas of king capturing
even so here we
have knight e to d6 this comes with
check king to e7 and now
even f5 opening up trying to open up the
f file
queen to h5 by morphe and here uh you
could continue with queen to a3 threaten
some nasty discoveries from
uh from the a3 square but uh owen goes
in
uh for for the kill with bishop to g5
this comes with
check and now we have king to d7 so if
you look at the position morphy's king
is still in the center of the board so
many pieces in front of morphe's king
the pawn here the queen is here
uh but it's not it's not at all clear
how to finish the game on the spot so
here
uh we have queen to g3 again queen to a3
is always an idea you just move this
knight shift to the queen to d6
could be very dangerous for morphe but
with queen to g3
now not allowing the queen to move as
the bishop is under attack also the e5
pawn is being threatened so maybe
captures in check is coming
a lot of a lot of possibilities here
however bishop to c7 by morphe
could could come in very useful uh and
here uh
well you could try a lot of things you
could try something like knight
uh captures an e5 with czech picking up
the bishop okay black will capture this
knight but it's still breaking through
you could try knight captures on b7 uh
also an idea however owen played queen
captures on e5 here and now
uh yes you are threatening this but it's
morphy's move so here morphy played rook
eight to e8
he uh uh kicked away the queen and the
queen captures on g7 now owen
threatening a lot of nasty discoveries
after this knight moves
uh and here morphy again shows uh how
very little he thinks
of his opponents he just plays bishop
captures on d6 and he allows
all sorts of nasty discoveries here you
you just have to kick away the queen
with rook h the g8 and then after the
queen moves
let's say you trade captures captures
and now you can capture on d6 and
there there are no problems if captures
then captures
and we would end this variation with
morphe having a knight and the bishop
for a rook however
uh morphy goes for bishop captures on d6
right away and now owen has a lot of
nasty discoveries
that he can go for like he could just
move the knight he could capture the
rook he could move the knight here he
could move it here he could capture the
bishop he could like do
do whatever and here owen went for
knight
to e5 with check uh this is
this is good knight captures and b6 was
better we're just going to show why it
was better because
it will again it comes with check king
captures here and now
the sneaky tricky variation of bishop to
f4
check uh that either forces the king on
the run which would be very unfortunate
as you
you can very easily pile up on the king
or you could accept the bishop and then
come to rook captures on f4 but now
uh this is being threatened and well
you're just up material you're in a much
better position the king is on d6
and if you if you try to save the bishop
let's say with bishop captures an f5
then we run into
rook to d for check king c5 and now rook
to c1 check
the rook is nicely defended so the king
has to go away it doesn't matter where
you go here or here if you go to
b6 then just rook checks uh the rook
will check followed by the queen
capturing
and if king b5 then the queen captures
right away then king a5 let's say rook
to c5 with mate
so that's what what happens and it was
definitely the way to go
so here uh owen misses his opportunity
uh he goes for knight to e5 with
check instead and now king the c8 by
morphy with queen to d7
check king to b8 and now queen captures
and d6 with
check so also a very a very uh
attractive line but
king the a8 and now comes uh well now he
plays it bishop to f4 he doesn't want
his bishop here as it's being threatened
but there is a very nice move here
knight captures on c6 a brilliant idea
uh point is that uh uh well that
if you capture the knight then you will
get the queen captures with
check and after keying to b8 now comes
bishop to f4 check again and that's a
problem
knight captures on f4 rook characters
and rook here will be
just a game over not not a lot of fun
for the black king so
what you would have to do after knight
captures on c6 you would have to go
queen captures on g5
but now queen captures on d5 and now
after b captures on c6 queen captures
king to b8
now the brilliant rook ate the c1
followed by rook c3
rook to b3 and not a lot of way for uh
for black to deal with this if rook to
c8 then you have the very clean
queen b5 check king to a8 and now queen
to d5 with
check king v8 and again rook to c3 with
the same idea either rook b3
or if it's captured then the thing is b
captures and
now uh you don't really have a good move
uh rook the b1 is coming and even if you
try and prevent it with bishop captures
uh the
the funny thing is you still get rook to
b1 check and you're either getting
checkmated or if bishop captures just
queen captures and it's a winning
winning game for white
so here after king a8 uh knight captures
here
tricky and hard to calculate but it is
the way to go
uh owen goes for bishop to f4 instead uh
he's still
he's still better here but the problem
is uh now morphy
morphy uh well he he starts being morphe
he plays queen captures on f5
uh and now that the bishop is out of
harm's way only now does owen go for
knight captures on c6
but now the only difference between this
knight captures on c6 and that knight
captures on c6 is that here
white loses by force and there is only
one move that uh
allows morphe to win the game so feel
free to pause the video and win this
game for morphe
while i give you a couple of seconds
so uh for those of you who were able to
do it congratulations on spotting such a
such a brilliant move that uh i know
it's uh
i know it's a odds game it's an odds
game so you know probably not
being showed a lot of places but you
know this movie is so brilliant that
you should show this game to everyone
especially your friends at the bar in
the library
uh but for all of you who just want to
enjoy the show it's bishop to h3
and it's such a such a wonderful move uh
the problem here
is that well you're just threatening a
lot of very nasty stuff one of them just
being bishop captures on g2 which starts
opening up the g
file but it's not easy to decline it for
example if you go bishop g3
you just try and defend get more pieces
into the defense open attack
against morphy's queen queen e4 comes
threatening checkmate and now the
problem is
uh no defense works for example if rook
f2 just bishop captures if rook captures
93 with a double attack now with the
knight in the queen
queen d2 defending now just queen
captures here and the position is
already terrible for white not just
terrible it's
dead lost but uh you don't have a move
let's say rook c1 you attack the queen
black can just trade everything off
captures captures captures captures
uh and now after rookie to check that's
just it you're gonna
start gobbling up pawns and your uh two
rooks against the rook and the bishop of
course completely winning for morphe
so bishop to h3 a really deadly idea
so here owen says okay it's not easy to
decline this sacrifice
let's try something else uh we might try
something like queen to c5 this is not
what he played i'm just uh
showing what he was probably thinking so
let's say we threaten mate here
problem is bishop captures on g2 king
captures and knight captures here just
picks up the queen
and you're again getting checkmated easy
game for black so here after bishop to
h3 owen said
all right obviously we must capture the
bishop which he did he played
g captures on h3 but now comes a
brilliant idea
queen to e4 with check first forcing the
king to the open g file
and only then uh continuing to remove
pieces from the board king g1
now knight captures on f4 so what do you
play here
morphe is already threatening checkmate
uh white has no such threat
so rook captures and now comes rook h
the g8
and believe it or not it was in this
position on move 33 that
john owen resigned the game as there is
nothing more to be done here point is if
you play something like king to f1
queen e2 is instant mate so you don't
have the option of moving the king
you could try blocking it let's say rook
g4 but then that rook
is kind of stuck here a simple h5 forces
resignation
because now you don't have a move uh
once you trade it's just again a very
simple matrix king of two rook checks
king f1 and now queen to e2 is again
checkmate so really wild game a really
wild odds game
where owen had the upper hand for the
entire game but
the game was morphe just you know kept
complicating kept complicating uh kept
complicating and
in the end uh where owen owen missed
this chance the problem is owen is a
really really strong player he's an
incredibly strong player the problem is
uh here in this position owen saw uh
knight to c6 but he didn't want to
like either spend too much time to
calculate or he couldn't calculate it
and then he said okay my bishop is
hanging so let's just move it we're
going to play this on the next move and
uh the thing is morphe just prepared it
with
this and then after uh owen finally
played this and he saw everything there
was this only one move that saves the
game uh which morphe of course played
uh and it's just uh just a brilliant
brilliant game
so uh once again uh i do hope you
enjoyed it uh if you're new to the
morphe saga click on the first link in
the description below it will take you
to all the previous videos we've done in
the paul morphy saga is
you do not want to miss it this guy is
is pretty awesome
i would also like to thank piero
composer uh peter dituri
jacques wenger uh alan callahan and mark
macleod for a contribution to my channel
thank you a lot i really appreciate it
as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here thank you for
watching and i will see you soon
continuing the coverage of the morphe
saga checking up on your wonderful
suggestions and whatever else happens in
the chess world
so thank you all i will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your saturday